jamais le valhalla n'a été aussi
affaiblie
j'entends respirer les ténèbres dans
respirer les dieux sont divisés
ça faisait longtemps que j'attendais que
l'enfant de la lumière vienne sauver le
hu
une guerre de milan a plongé le valhalla
dans des ténèbres le rock
tu as peur peut-être ta je verrai sur
toi
le loup fenrir a réussi à s'échapper si
jamais les jeunes notre monde n'en ont
rappelé pour longtemps
à toi
la destinée n'est connue de personne
que tous les guerriers se tient prête
ton voyage ne fait que commencer
nous sommes les seuls capables
d'empêcher la prophétie fumée
star
seul son marteau sera capable de venir à
bout de berne l'office